[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESS FRAME: Good
afternoon, folks.
We'd like to introduce you
to the basics of SRE today--
at least how we
do this at Google.
So, reliability.
Obviously it's important to us.
A lot of things
keep us up at night.
We want to make sure that
we don't have outages
because of lack of power.
We want to make sure
that's a bad code
release doesn't completely
stop us in our tracks.
We want to make sure that we
don't lose a bunch of customers
during Black Friday because
we have gotten overloaded
and cannot serve capacity,
and latency goes flat,
and nobody gets responses.
So at Google, we approach
this with the establishment
of the Site Reliability
Engineering group.
And who are we to talk
to you about this?
I'm Jess Frame.
I've been at Google for
a bit over a decade, half
as a developer, half
as a SRE, working
in platforms, and cloud, and
social, and a few other groups.
In cloud, I've actually worked
on App Engine networking
and the Customer
Reliability Engineering
group I'm with right now, which
you'll hear more about later.
ANN WALLACE: Hi,
I'm Ann Wallace.
I am a cloud consultant
with professional services
at Google.
I've been at Google a
little less than a year.
And prior to Google, I
spent 14 years at Nike
in various operations,
engineering and architecture
roles.
So today we're going to
talk about five key areas.
First, we're going to talk
about the core problems
that SRE solves.
Second, we're going to talk
about the key principles
SRE uses to keep systems
appropriately reliable.
Then we'll dive into the
responsibility and expertise
that SREs have.
Forth, we'll pull
all this together
and talk about how you can
adopt some of the SRE practices
within your organization.
And then, lastly, we'll talk
about how Google could help you
with this.
So let's go ahead
and get started
in talking about what SRE is.
But first, let's talk about
what makes us unreliable,
and how SRE helps to
solve these things.
Going to see if
this thing works.
Ah, perfect.
So-- oops, we went back.
Skipping.
Sorry about that.
OK, here we go.
So traditionally,
product development teams
or engineering teams
spend a lot of their time
designing, developing
new features
for projects and applications.
But once those are ready
to go into production,
those teams typically
move on to the next thing.
And really, the majority
of the total cost
of ownership of software is
after it's in production.
So if you think-- one
month of development time
is really equal to 10 months
of production support.
So if these engineering teams
aren't managing the software
once it's in production, who is?
I'm not going to
use this clicker.
Sorry about that.
All right, so, again,
we have the developers
who are working on
the new features.
And once those are ready
to go into production,
they kind of throw it
over the proverbial wall
to the operations team.
And the operations team, they
deploy it into production.
But more than deploying
it in production,
they're the team
that's responsible
for the reliability,
scalability, and maintenance
of the software.
And more than just
the software, it's
the servers and services and
infrastructure the software
is running on.
And in my experience, there
is a lot more emphasis
put on hiring for
the development teams
and operations team.
So you get a lot more features
going over to the operations
team, and the operations
team can't juggle
everything that's going on.
It causes a lot of friction
between these teams,
and it's just not scalable.
It's a fragile model here.
So reducing the product
lifecycle friction.
So we start with a business.
A business or product
management teams
are the ones that make
these feature requests that
go to the development teams.
Development teams then
implement these features,
which then gets handed off
to the operations team.
So you have these barriers
between these teams,
a lot of friction.
So we have we have agile
methodology that breaks down
the barrier between the
business and development teams.
But it doesn't really
help with the barriers
between the development
and operations team.
So this is where
DevOps comes in.
So we think of DevOps,
really, in five key areas.
First, we want to
break down that wall.
This helps with the
collaboration and velocity
between the development
and operation team.
Second, we know things
are going to break.
We plan for that.
We accept failure as normal.
Two, smaller changes are
easy to implement and deploy.
Which also makes them easier
to rollback, which helps us
with the meantime to recovery.
Four, we want to remove
human error from the equation
wherever possible.
And we do this leveraging,
tooling, and automation.
And fifth, we want to
measure everything,
because measurement is
critical to determine
success, especially of
these first four areas.
So the SRE approach
to operations.
We SRE like to treat operations
as an engineering problem.
We hire people who don't
want to do repetitive work
and will create
automated solutions.
We use data to guide decisions
and help prioritize what
we're going to work on next.
You can go to the next slide.
So what do SRE
teams at Google do?
The SRE teams are not
simply just engineers
who carry the pagers.
SRE folks are
systems engineers who
develop solutions and
manage large, distributed,
complex systems at scale.
The SRE teams at
Google have a saying
where they like to automate
this year's job away,
because there are more
interesting problems
to solve the next year.
So if we think of DevOps as a
programming interface, an SRE,
or class SRE, implements DevOps.
DevOps is really a
cultural practice
that breaks down the
silos between not just
the operations and
engineering teams
but your network teams,
your security team,
the architecture teams.
And site reliability
engineering is
a set of those practices we
found to work and a job role.
So now I'm going to
hand this over to Jess
to talk a little bit about
the key principles of SRE.
JESS FRAME: Cool.
ANN WALLACE: Is that working?
JESS FRAME: Nope, mine
is also doing doubles.
ANN WALLACE: OK, sweet.
JESS FRAME: Have fun.
[LAUGHING]
So, much of the feedback
loops that drive our paradigm
have to do with
the error budget.
And we don't expect
you to know what
this means at all right now.
So we want to,
from the ground up,
establish the significance
of this with you,
and how we came to
this conclusion.
So first of all, our
goal is reliability.
We need to go through and
determine how we measure this.
The user is the most
important feature in all this.
So the naive approach
doesn't always
work for depending
on your service,
depending on how
it's distributed.
Good minutes and total minutes
was historically a very common
thing, but this may actually
not be a good representation
of user happiness.
So instead, we
like to step back--
ask you all to step back--
and think how the users are
interacting with the system,
and instead figure out what
the interaction measurement is.
And whether that's queries or
uptime ping or other things,
if you're more of an MMO.
ANN WALLACE: Did I go too fast?
JESS FRAME: So this moves
the whole focal point
of the success measurement
away from the underlying
individual machines
and code, and off
to what the user actually sees.
And we all know whatever
we measure is what
ends up being optimized for.
So making sure this
measurement is done well
is the most important thing.
So reliability is often
presented as a goal of nines.
You've probably seen
this thing before.
Honestly, it looks
big and scary,
particularly when you get up
to three nines bang nine hours
of outage here.
But even at Google
for a measurement,
five nines is only maintained
by a small number of teams.
This is partly because it takes
a lot of money to achieve that.
So the underlying infrastructure
is the most important thing
to get moving with that.
But also, honestly, your
individual services,
the reliability of your
ISPs and cellular networks,
and everything else often
will hit before that,
and people can't
tell the difference.
So what about 100%?
Really, the world
is not about 100%.
Nothing is certain.
Our advice from
running years and years
of large-scale services is,
it's not worth the money.
Its near impossible.
Even if we as humanity
had the technology,
it comes at a hefty price.
It comes at very slow change and
features, features, features.
That's not something we want.
And each of those nines is
really an exponential cost.
It's not linear.
You can spend all of
the money in the world
trying to make something.
Just count the number,
and not to fail ever.
So we were talking
about availability.
Are SLO-- our Service Level
Objective-- is actually
what we term this internally.
It is our goal.
The main consequence for
this is shame internally,
because we have high
standards for ourselves.
The indicators are the
metrics and other signals
that we use to measure this,
and display it on graphs,
and do the quarterly reports.
The SLAs end up
being what's often
shared with external
customers, and the consequences
of that with legal teams
involved tends to be money.
So again, focusing on user
happiness, getting a good SLO
is not as easy as it seems.
But the most important thing to
start with is, keep it simple.
And you will iterate
through and get
something more and more solid.
Without backing data,
you revise, you learn.
That's the only way
to go forward with it.
For example, it
may be unintuitive
that you can set a low SLO
and achieve it every day.
But if the user
expects higher of you,
you will get complaints
before your pager goes off.
And that is a very large issue.
So vital to the
SRE approach here
is that we get these
three groups in agreement.
It's not going to
be easy, but it is--
without these three being on
the same reliability goal,
and with the promise
to support and defend
each person that's
trying to maintain that,
we can' move forward.
If we don't have agreement,
if we don't have support,
it doesn't matter if we're
handed the keys to the system.
We won't be able to
work on it properly.
It's hard to get this agreement,
but there's luckily a few tools
that can be used with this.
One is pointing out
the exponential cost
to the business people.
If they want 100%, that's going
to be very, very expensive.
And chances are they don't
want to spend the money on it.
There's a trade-off between
reliability and speed
with the developers, and they
probably want to move fast.
And in all of this
system, the users
will push back with unhappiness
if it is not reliable enough,
and they will go elsewhere.
So this all system will
iterate, but you can get there.
So having decided on
a target and going
through how we measure it,
and having an agreement
between the three
groups, we're going
to go back to the error budget.
Which really is the reverse
of the availability target.
And what this is is how
much time you can be down
and how many requests
you can fail in order
to further getting releases
out, faster change, progress,
all of that.
Because we want to build things.
We don't actually
want to say no to you.
Ever.
We have common goals here.
The error budgets luckily
make this nice feedback loop
of having shared goals,
so we have less conflict
and less churn.
We're all on the same team here.
We all want a
successful product,
no matter how much
the [INAUDIBLE] people
look like the bad
people to say, no,
we've had too much downtime.
You need to cut off and
not do any more releases.
The developers and
others eventually
learn that this is all
for the good of all of us.
This whole thing encourages
more responsible expectations
and velocity as well
from the various teams.
So we were going over the
DevOps principles earlier.
This is kind of how
the error budget
paradigm fits within them.
So you get the
ownership of the silos.
You get the error budgets
themselves, which quantify it,
which is vital.
And how you measure the
reliability is very important.
So the concept of SLO and error
budget are all well and good,
but what do we actually look
like day to day as our job?
We're going to go over
our areas of expertise
here, although where
the lines are drawn
vary from company to company.
I've seen a bit
of variety there.
So most of those
are pretty obvious.
Metrics are comment.
Capacity is necessary.
Helping with the
change management.
Emergency response is kind
of our bread and butter.
But culture is one of
the interesting ones that
isn't always pointed out but
is actually the most vital,
and everybody is
responsible for it.
It's not just the SREs.
Without the culture
being supported
by the business and developers,
it's hard to continue.
So monitoring, alerting.
Pretty basic.
We do suggest two
different priorities--
paging and tickets,
depending on how bad
the system is hurt right
now, or if it's impending,
to avoid in the future.
And the most scary
thing in the world
right there is
noisy urgent alerts.
That is where it will
burn out your people.
This is what will end up
with your system not getting
the attention that it needs.
There's a relevant story
here about crying wolf,
but still, I see
this pattern a lot,
of just a whole bunch
of little alerts
that are treated urgent and the
same level as the whole system
being down.
So obviously to
serve traffic, it's
going to take some resources.
And one's either going
to have to solve this
with planning your resources
over time, auto scaling,
or just having absurd
amounts of capacity in case
you have large spikes
to avoid outages.
The last option
definitely does not
become a possibility the
larger you grow, though.
Planning becomes more and
more vital at that point.
Even if money isn't an issue,
tracking on the resources
is absolutely vital so you can
see when something happens,
if it is a feature
that you want launched,
and you're acknowledging that
that was a cost you had to it.
Or if this is a bug that's just
going to get worse and worse--
a memory leak.
Different teams handle
this differently.
We prescribed by
rollback immediately
when we see something
bad, and investigate then.
So working together with
how changes are introduced.
Working together with the
development teams often
actually means we can
combine the infrastructure,
and allow the developers
to move faster.
Which isn't as intuitive
but there's normally
a lot of low-hanging fruit
there, as far as things
that will both make the SREs
and the developers happy.
Some of those are
progressive rollouts
and all those other things.
A lot of that allows you
to test on a smaller pool
and confirm before--
so you can release the faster--
get the release out faster.
So we all want to move faster,
despite common misconceptions
with SRE.
And the developers can
move as fast as they
want in our paradigm, actually.
The big wall there
is the error budget.
And if the error budget gets
hit, they have to freeze.
And they have to freeze
until it's recovered again.
So most dev teams-- this is
a nice feedback loop of they
prefer to take a partial
hit and not fully freeze
but know that they're
near the budget.
Because if they never
actually exceed,
they don't have to stop.
If they exceed,
they have to stop
until it's recovered again.
If it's a bad enough
outage, it may be a month
until you actually can start
releasing your features again,
which is something nobody wants.
So provisioning.
Having the capacity
is one thing.
Making sure that it
is obtained swiftly,
and that when it is actually
integrated into the system
that it doesn't break is
equally important to having it
in the first place.
If you have an outage because
you added a new region,
and the system
isn't expecting it,
that is possibly
worse than actually
not having the capacity
at all and just dropping
the extra queries.
So what we are known most
for is emergency response.
But surprisingly, this
is actually largely--
training and support is
responsible for our success.
I've had a lot of
good developers
that were hesitant
to try being on call,
try the SRE role at all.
But we have this lovely
program internally
called mission control,
and we'll bring them over.
And the majority of them
are able to do on call.
A number of the
most hesitant ones
actually end up being the
best of our SREs, which
is a really exciting thing see.
And it's a matter of
not panicking, making
sure we have support,
knowing that you're not going
to be blamed if you reach out.
The system is more
important than your own ego.
You're not going to be harmed
financially for it, either.
So starting with the outages
and the postmortems afterwards,
we need to determine how
bad an outage actually
needs a postmortem.
It's very important to be clear
on consistency of incident size
and the standing definition
for the clarity of all parties
involved on what to expect.
Postmortems are probably the
most vital part of our culture.
It's how we learn from
what's happened in the past.
It's the most frustrating thing
in the world to repeat outages,
whether it's the exact
same one or a pattern,
over and over again.
We're here to learn more
things and make it more stable.
This is one of the big,
scary ones, culture-wise.
This is something
that is hard to do.
It's not easy.
Our job is absolutely impossible
without support of our choices,
though, when we're on call.
We can be handed a big system.
If we're not handed the equal
trust and responsibility
to go with that
system, then we are
afraid to make the choices
that are necessary to recover
the system.
We'll instead stick
to what's documented,
stick to what we know we
won't get in trouble for,
as opposed to taking our
knowledge of the system
and doing what we need
to patch it again.
And this is valuable not just
during the outage but at all
times.
Which includes during
the postmortem.
Unavoidably, some of our
day-to-day work will be ops.
That's how it goes.
We are part software
engineer, we are part systems
engineer and ops.
The important
thing here, though,
is that we need the
support to make choices
on what to automate and when.
So we can take away all of
these manual, repetitive tasks,
and instead spend our
time on better things.
Without that, you're not going
to have a system that scales.
You're just going to throw more
and more people into the bucket
until it actually gets fixed.
And the best of your
people will end up bored,
which Ann mentioned earlier.
We have better problems
to fix next year.
The team skills.
We like a 50/50 mix.
This often means when
you're converting
from a traditional ops
version to actually keeping
all of those ops people,
almost all of them
will be happy to work with you.
And their knowledge is
absolutely invaluable.
Everybody should
be able to code.
We do enforce that.
But that is also so that the
system engineers don't end up
with all of the ops work.
We want to be treated as equals.
We want the respect
to be in both ways.
We don't want to
bucket the work.
That creates silos
that are unnecessary.
It's not very teamlike.
And again, we will point
out that empowering the SREs
is the most vital thing
in the world for this.
If you punish the SREs
for doing their job,
if you don't give them
the necessary escalation
tools, if you don't back them
when they say this is too much,
the system is
going to fall over,
you're going to have an outage.
They are the people who
know most about this,
and you have put
this trust in them.
So, a recap of
our SRE principles
and some of the examples
of how that comes in.
And again, pulling back
to DevOps with a few
more examples of how we have
the SRE paradigm apply to that.
ANN WALLACE: Cool.
So you have all that, right?
So now we're going
to talk about how
you can get started taking
some of what we've talked about
and using it in
your organization.
Magic.
JESS FRAME: I got it.
ANN WALLACE: OK, so first,
start with these four things.
Start with service
level objectives.
SLOs are the combined agreement
between the product, dev,
and SRE teams.
Without SLOs, you don't
have error budgets.
Having both of these
helps prioritize the work.
Two, hire system engineers
who can write software.
They're going to
end up automating
a lot of that manual work
that was done traditionally
by the ops team.
Three, treat your
product and operations
or system engineering
teams the same.
We're all software
engineers at the core.
We want them to have respect
between the two teams,
not have that wall that you're
just throwing crap over.
And then four, we
want to make sure
that the SRE teams are
able to choose their work.
So for example, if the error
budgets continually go over,
get exceeded, and the
products engineering team's
not helping out,
then the SRE team
should be able to deprioritize
support for that service.
SREs are valuable
and scarce, so we
want to use their time wisely.
So you've got this.
Pick one service.
Pick something simple.
Run it through the SRE model.
Make sure that your
team feels empowered,
that they have support from
management and so forth.
I mean, you check and make
sure that your services are
up and running.
Make sure you check in
with the team health.
Because change is hard.
We all have to adjust.
Things are going to fail.
People are going to make
mistakes through this process.
That's OK.
And using things like the
blameless postmortems helps.
It's an iterative process.
But once you feel like you've
kind of got this dialed in,
it doesn't have to be perfect.
Become the internal advocate.
Take that service that you've
run through the SRE model,
and start talking to
other teams internally.
You're going to find people
who are excited about this.
And they're are going
to be your people.
They're going to be your
internal advocate team.
And you just keep
talking and showing this,
and you're just
going to start seeing
some of the SRE practices
pop up in your company.
And it's just going
to continue to evolve.
And we're here to help.
So we'll talk about
a few ways that you
can engage with Google.
JESS FRAME: As I
mentioned earlier,
I am part of the Customer
Reliability team.
We help you learn how
to in your own team.
We'll actually come in and
do workshops, do meetings
where we help you set SLOs,
build your monitoring,
build your SRE team itself.
We are all SREs.
We've all served on
different teams at Google.
So we have some background
on how to get the advocacy,
how to get the different
structures and, of course,
all the technical bits
with postmortems and things
like reel of misfortune,
which is an exercise we do,
running through fake
pages with newbies
so they are more
comfortable with on call.
So, how to get us a CRE is
a little more interesting,
though, because there is
not a lot of us right now.
There's 20, 30 of us
worldwide, somewhere in there.
So you're going to
contact your TAM,
but you've got to keep
in mind your executives,
your C levels need to
be behind the process.
Because again, we were talking
about the culture support.
Ultimately, if
somebody is not happy,
they're going to come and
escalate, and escalate,
and they have to be supported.
And interestingly,
CRE is a group
that you don't pay
for the services.
Partly because of our
expertise, partly because we're
a scarce resource.
But you do pay with your
willingness and time.
So we do expect you
to have homework
with each of the workshops.
Like, we may help you
build a few of the SLOs.
We're going to
expect the rest back.
We're going to expect to
see you building the metrics
and showing us the graphs, so we
know that you're there with us
and ready for the next step.
ANN WALLACE: Cool, so
there's also a Professional
Services, a group I'm part of.
We're a paid
service, but we come
in-- we can help
organizations by doing intro
to SRE workshops, or more
advanced SLO workshops.
So you pick a
couple of services,
and we run through
some of the SRE models
and help you to find
those SLOs, and what
would happen if your error
budget gets exceeded,
and so forth.
And it also could be
companies that might not
meet the criteria yet for CREs.
We could help with that.
And then maybe eventually
get people like Jess help.
So, again, you can contact your
sales or your TAMs, or ping us.
We also have books.
So we have the "Site Reliability
Engineering" book that's
been out for a little while.
The workbook that's
just been released.
JESS FRAME: We've got some
launch day copies over
at the five nines.
So come visit us.
We've got a bunch of CREs there.
A few SREs from
other teams as well.
And if you'd like to start
reading that before you engage
us, that is an opportunity to
see if you are on the same page
and want to execute this.
ANN WALLACE: And "Seeking
SRE" is coming soon.
Thank you all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]